[Music]
let's go to mary in
seattle home of allison chains what's up
mary
hey how are you dr john i'm good how are
you
good now my blood pressure is up
oh you heard that last call
yes lately
um
so what's up so
we just bought a farm we my husband oh
you and your family my husband okay
great yep
and my husband is gone during most of
the kids awake hours
so my question is how do we survive this
and find balance between
family life church and
the farm oh man so tell me about this
transition to buy a farm why'd you guys
buy a farm
my husband has been a dairy farmer his
entire life
he went to school to study
agriculture
and it's been his dream his entire life
and we finally
were able to do that
and it's been it's it's been a difficult
transition and i also
struggle with
being jealous of other families that are
living normal lives
because he works every day of the week
every single day there's been a big push
there's been a big push across the
country you know the last like with hdtv
and all these little
like build your own uh
you know uh
secret home in the wilderness
shows on youtube and stuff that people
have flocked out there and i did the
same thing i don't have a farm i just
got five or six acres
it's a lot of work
like it's yeah the chicken's gotta be
fed every day and they gotta be let out
every day and the dogs have to be this
and whatever yes you gotta fix the fence
every week and so it's a lot it's a lot
more work than people think when you say
you're jealous of normal people do you
wish you were living in the suburb in a
4-3 just no in the life
no i just
like i'll see
somebody's
husband sledding with their kids on a
weekend and i'm like ah okay do you
realize how lucky you are oh man yeah
that's how i feel and it
i i keep hearing that this is the life
of a farmer's wife and
do i suck it up deal with it or
do i do i be the change
mary you're drowning
i my husband also has a very strong work
ethic so i think there are times where
it is good it's a blessing but
i believe there are times where
he can come home
but he just doesn't know how to turn it
off he's like well i also should do this
and this and this and this
what is it about home that isn't a safe
place for him
i don't i don't think it's a
let me set a different way let me ask
you not that you've made a uh unsafe
house for him that's how i'm trying to
imply
um
sometimes
not sometimes we naturally all lean
towards
the things that we feel that we are the
best at
and
if i know i can fix a tractor i'm gonna
sit out there and keep working on this
tractor and it's gotta get fixed anyway
right i don't have the money to pay
somebody so that's but i know how this
thing works i'm gonna keep leaning into
that
is there a
reality that he knows if he goes back
inside
he doesn't really know how to deal with
the five-year-old and i don't know how
old your kids are but that there is a
lack of efficacy there
and there's some shame there's some uh
like i
i should know how to do this because i'm
a dad and so i'm just gonna wrap my dad
up in making sure everything's taken
care of at the farm and wife will take
care of the kids you know what i mean
like there's this lack of efficacy there
i think he definitely feels some guilt
to an extent because
he has mentioned that when he's coming
home he wonders if me and the kids will
still be there yeah not because i have
made threats
i i've been trying really hard to be
supportive of this
endeavor
but
i i am the one that disciplines the kids
and
raises them right it's we have a four
and a half and a two-year-old oh man
okay and
and you're lonely up there over him
yeah
i mean i i have good friends that make
an effort to come over and they're
willing to
the kids along with me but
it definitely i'm a people person i need
people around me all the time
and so
and a four and a half year old and a
two-year-old and a couple of goats won't
cut that right
and you know it's
it's a lot of cows a lot of cows can i
can i poke one one step further
yep do you find yourself
really annoyed with him and really
annoyed with these kids
and you just want to have people and
then you feel guilty that you feel
annoyed
yes i get i feel very guilty yes because
you're supposed to be the farmer's wife
you're supposed to be the mom that just
loves being with her kids and what and
sometimes you just want to leave them
and go to a starbucks in a city and hang
out with your friends
i do i sometimes want to just run away
and come back later that day but
um
i i feel
guilty getting a sitter and leaving and
i feel guilty when i
am gone in the morning if i go out to
coffee with someone with the kids i feel
guilty when i don't bring food to the
farm and
i i try really hard to set
the note on a positive note when he
comes in but there are definitely times
when it's he comes in
hours
after he said he would and i i am kind
of annoyed you should be
you're right you're right to be annoyed
so
here's a how long how long ago did y'all
buy this farm
two months okay so we're this isn't a
couple of years you're 60 days in right
yep okay which we also have had
like every weather extreme you can think
of right you bought it you bought a farm
in the middle of the winter
right
but he has been
he was managing a different farm
and um
i know what it's like being married to a
farmer i i think i know what it's like
by now
well
tell me about your marriage before you
bought this farm
were things heading in this direction
anyway not that your marriage is bad but
were they heading in this way anyway
no um
the last two years were a bit of a
struggle
i lost my little brother
and
i'm sorry i hit um that that's that's a
whole different
thing but i just think i hit
my lowest point
and he was unsure how to deal with that
because he's never
he's never dealt with anyone that's
struggled with mental health there you
go
is that even mental health that's grief
that's a deep deep black yeah and i
think like i don't think he ever even
properly grieved the loss of him it was
yeah i don't know it was
so here's a here's a here's the thing
that happens it's quite common okay
so you
have a deep loss
and the guy you've tethered your life to
doesn't handle it in the right way let's
just call it what it is
and part of you raises an eyebrow to
that
he's not exactly what you needed to him
to be in that moment
and you we don't have a playbook for
that
right it's it's similar not exactly but
it's similar to finding out somebody
maybe wasn't cheating on you but was
having a
texting
thing with somebody at work
right it's
oh i i didn't
i thought you'd be there and you weren't
or i thought you were this and you're
not
and we often don't have a playbook for
that and that one little splinter
whether it's a little splinter or a big
one and here's the thing i've done this
in my own house by the way
i didn't respond well to my wife's grief
and
i tried to expert her i tried to give
her a bunch of lectures and a bunch of
data points and i
blew it
and what i didn't realize was how deeply
i hurt her and how deep our our
the fracture in our relationship went
and the healing that had to happen there
began with her
bravery saying
i'm still not okay and this happened a
long time ago i'm still not okay
and i had to hear it and i had to take
it because it was right
and that that one act of bravery and
vulnerability
allowed me and her to then say where are
we now
and i had set up this future i mean this
dream for us mine was to be a college
president it wasn't to own a farm but
being a college president requires you
to do this and you do that and you run
all hours of the night and you're a part
of this committee and that committee and
you're on this thing with the city and
you're getting another degree in that
like it's that same life it's just with
a suit on instead of with dickies on
right
hope y'all in seattle hopefully he wears
filson every day right like he's very
filthy no filson like the
oh oh no no no not there
somewhere else but okay so
anyway he
ultimately it was is this the life this
is the life we said we wanted we're
getting closer to it is this really who
we want to be and the answer ultimately
was no
in that season the answer was no
and so you're two months in did y'all
take out a bunch of debt to buy this
farm
yep deal in the hole yeah so you're
scared financially you're all alone
you got a guy that you have trust issues
with not because you think he's cheating
on you i
i don't want to make him sound like he's
terrible he's not
he was there for me
when we were like
when we
when we lost my brother it was just the
aftermath of
me
going back mentally to a place where he
has never been part of my life right so
hear me say mary and he was very
confused yeah i'm not talking bad about
him at all not even a little bit i'm him
like we're the same guy okay
and i i know my heart through the whole
thing was was was good i know what i was
trying to do was good i knew i was
leaning into the things that i knew i
could do well and when i didn't know how
to connect with my wife because i felt
the gap i just didn't know what it was
i started leaning into the things that i
was good at which was work
which was helping other people with
their problems in the middle of the
night which was running around police
officers and with
marginalized population i mean i started
running around that way because i knew i
could be successful there
and what happens is over time that golf
because it's bigger and bigger and
bigger so in no way am i saying he's a
bad guy in fact i think the opposite i
think he's a great guy
i think you're great and i think he's
great and i think you're
both have pictures of what the other
person should be doing or you both have
pictures of what you thought your life
would be and now here it is and it's not
what you want
and that's okay
the problem is most of us don't own
where we're coming from
and if we don't own the reality of where
we're sitting where we're coming from
what's happening right now in real time
we can't be about fixing it and what you
said haunts me
is this just the way this is should i
just suck this up
the number of wives i've talked to over
the years who just said well he just was
going to be a bank president so this was
kind of my life
i can't tell you how many people i've
talked to i can't tell you how many men
i've talked to said well i mean
i mean i was just going to take the next
promotion right why would i not take the
promotion and suddenly they find
themselves in a job that they hate
at a place that they hate
making good money
and their life is
miserable right so
i want you to hear me say what you and
your husband are experiencing is super
common the challenge is you all went all
in financially you owe a lot of money on
this thing he's feeling a lot of
pressure you're feeling a lot of
pressure there's financial insecurity
there's trust and i don't say trust like
he's gonna cheat on you but trust or
you're gonna cheat on him but trust like
you've got stuff going on you got
secrets that you're keeping from him
about how hard this is and he's got
secrets he's keeping from you about how
much he misses y'all but he bought this
farm it was his dream he's got to make
this thing work
and what i'm saying is you all need to
have a where are we now 60 day
conversation
you've got to say i'm not okay and you
got to give him permission to say
tell me you're not okay because i bet
he's if he came and said we just spent a
million dollars on a farm
is it more than that
yeah yeah we spent more than a million
dollars on a farm
i don't think i love it or i can't do
all this by myself
or i knew this was gonna be hard but i
didn't realize i was gonna miss my
entire children's life
those are some conversations he needs to
be able to say out loud and he probably
doesn't have a
like a map for how to do that right so
no
so
i i want to continue being supportive
but i think i also need to
put my foot down
in some areas like him
coming home for dinner yes because
he
he will
i'll tell him that he'll come home for
dinner two nights and then he calls me
and says
i could cut drop everything and come now
and he always has to go back out in the
evening
or he says i could come in
and be done for the night at seven
o'clock and i can help put the kids to
bed and i know he will not make it in at
seven o'clock right so what we're
getting i don't want to be no no no
it's not about what you don't want to be
you're talking about integrity issues
now
you're talking about you said and i'm
holding you to your word
it's integrity like we have two kids
you're a part of their lives
and so i think there's a there's some
boundary conversations that need to
happen
which is you're a functioning part of
this home i need you here i want you
here not even i need you i want you here
the kids want you here
and if we need to hire some help then
we'll hire some help even though we
can't afford it if we like whatever the
thing is fine but this i gotta go back
out till seven
maybe in a season right so i'm about to
launch a book i'm about to enter a
season that's gonna be bonkers for the
next three or four months my wife and i
sat down we talked about it we game
planned it we got a we got our calendars
out i talked to my kids about it
and i'm making sure that i
loop back around on some other time with
my kids
right because they don't understand as
much as they're like yeah cool dad they
don't get it and that's not they
shouldn't they're kids
but
we are super intentional about what the
next season's going to look like and
this thing ends with a pretty long
vacation this summer
this ends with me and my wife going
somewhere this ends with the kids coming
us with us on a thing so
like there's a there's a light at the
end of the tunnel you don't have a light
at the end of the tunnel you just got
darkness and you're like ah so if you
look at it like i'm gonna put my foot
down
you're making your relationship miiverse
him
and you may have to get there with your
boundaries i'd much rather see you lean
in at the beginning and say hey i'm
struggling i'm not okay
i know what being a farmer's wife is
like i didn't know i was gonna be a
single parent i miss you
i really miss you
the kids miss you
and i don't know what's going on at the
farm but we need to be have better
communication if you say you're gonna be
in i need you here for dinner every day
and i need when you get at dinner i need
you to be done for the day and not work
all through the night
and then we can get up and you can get
up and go again tomorrow i mean some of
those conversations are great but that's
talking about i put my foot down you
have to is different than i need you
here you know what i'm saying and he may
say sorry honey i just can't do it well
then you cros that's when you say okay
well here's my boundary and then you're
gonna have to have your or what
conversation with yourself
which is or what i'm gonna leave i'm
gonna take these kids and say nope we're
going to be around people and other
things you don't want us in your life
anyway so we're going to go ahead and
move on
or you're going to say no i'm just going
to suck it up and this is going to be
the rest of my life
and my hope is yeah i don't get there i
don't think he's that kind of guy
do you no he's not i don't either it
sounds like he's a guy who doesn't know
how to
start this conversation and a gift would
be
for you to start it with him
okay okay and maybe you say hey here
what's three things you love about our
new farm what are three things that are
killing you about the new farm and you
go first
and that gives him a way to lean into it
a little bit you know what i mean
yeah
you'll sound completely disconnected
[Music]
are y'all still holding hands and
looking at each other and smiling or is
it just all been work work work work
work
when we see each other
we
we don't see each other
that often and
i i mean
we
if we do go out to date night or
whatever he is pretty tired yeah he's
he's
pretty burnt out so okay so i think
there's something about first fruits
family family gets family gets
the best of you
where it gets part two
and i know that's not a popular saying
these days but
like
if all i give my family is whatever
little bit i've got left after giving my
all at work
um
then my family will never know me
my kids will never be tethered to
anything firm
my wife will not know affection and care
and love and vice versa it happens with
the other way around too
so it's time for a hard conversation
that i hope you can have in love and
hope you can have with the spirit of
we're in this together and if you both
say let's sell the farm like we're gonna
we lost
we're gonna lose it all or whatever
let's sell the farm sell the farm
fill the farm
your marriage is more important than the
farm your kid's more important in the
farm than some dream
sometimes that dream we've had for a
long long time turns out to be a
nightmare
he's lucky to have you he's lucky to
have you